[Musica]
quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare a
te dedex ho detto Caspita cosa mai avrò
io da raccontare No perché ho
semplicemente realizzato i miei sogni e
la fortuna di aver incontrato 27 anni fa
mio marito e con lui aver fondato una
piccola Ong in Zambia chiamata pamaza
indiana che in lingua locale vuol dire
assieme ai bambini
da poco ho terminato di leggere un libro
Don Chisciotte e amico Sancio cambiare
il mondo non è follia né utopia ma solo
giustizia Ecco questa citazione l'ho
sempre fatta molto mia molto nostra
Perché la nostra scelta di vita di
partire per l'Africa e dedicarci agli
altri è stato un po' cambiare il mondo
renderlo un po' migliore sono sempre
stato un po' ribelle e 27 anni fa ho
deciso di partire per l'Africa e mi sono
lasciata un po' trascinare dall'impulso
e mi sono
unita un gruppo che partiva per lo
Zambia in una missione dei padri
comboniani e il gruppo lo organizzava
Enrico e lì ci siamo conosciuti
ci sono tantissimi la prima volta ma ci
siamo capiti subito
stessi ideali entrambi sognatori
incoscienti giovani come dicono gli
inglesi young and foolish adesso siamo
un po' più vecchi ma sempre incoscienti
Holden foolish
e quindi una volta che siamo rientrati
in Italia dallo Zambia è stato naturale
pensare di ripartire assieme sposati
E
perché entrambi volevamo vivere una vita
diversa
dal si deve fare così perché così deve
essere per cui siamo partiti per
l'Africa per lo Zambia abbiamo fatto
cinque anni di volontariato nella
missione dei Padri comuniani Giuseppe il
nostro primo figlio è nato in Africa
mentre i gemelli Filippo e Damiano sono
nati in Italia ma cresciuti in Africa
anche loro
dopo cinque anni ci siamo trasferiti
nella città più vicina cipata perché in
missione non c'era una scuola che poteva
garantire un'educazione adeguata ai miei
ragazzi
e
però ci sono spostati una roba senza
lavoro perché sono sempre stati
volontari e pensando in modo logico
adesso 51 anni avremmo potuto rientrare
in Italia e riprendere le file della
nostra vita ma
la nostra i nostri ideali con gli stessi
ideali che ci avevano fatto partire per
l'Africa ci hanno detto no noi non
molliamo restiamo Eh perché vabbè è
sempre stato il mio moto
quindi ci siamo spostati in città e
dopo due anni più o meno di un po' di
fatica e abbiamo trovato entrambi lavoro
per una organizzazione italiana e le
cose iniziavano a essere normali anche
per noi Giuseppe era in terza elementare
i gemelli avevano iniziato la preistone
in questa scuola internazionale
Quando ecco la scuola decide di chiudere
per mancanza di bambini perché le
famiglie di espatriati avevano deciso di
rientrare nei loro paesi e ancora una
volta ci siamo trovati di fronte a un
bivio a decidere cosa fare e ancora una
volta la nostra voglia di portare avanti
i nostri sogni Ci ha fatto dire never
che va noi restiamo però ci siamo posti
il problema dell'educazione cosa fare
perché comunque la scelta di venire in
Africa è stata mia di Enrico non dei
ragazzi Noi volevamo dare garantire a
loro l'e descrizione per permettere a
loro di prendere il loro decisioni in
libertà e qui sono io Mamma infermiera
dovevo fare da maestra ai miei ragazzi
senza conoscere bene l'inglese Tra
l'altro e qui sono iniziati gli anni
della home School e per 13 anni sono
diventata maestra e mamma dei miei
ragazzi
sono stati anni meravigliosi sofferti ma
meravigliosi ragazzi hanno iniziato
parlano inglesi italiano zambiano si
sono Confrontati con culture religioni
diverse
colori diversi non era più il bianco e
il nero ma era il bianco il grigio il
nero una girandola di esperienza abbiamo
fatto e
la forza nostra è stata anche quella di
avere una casa aperta È passato il mondo
Abbiamo avuto un sacco di persone che
hanno voluto
condividere un pezzettino della nostra
strada e far vedere che comunque vivere
in modo diverso era possibile
poi c'è stata anche la malattia
diagnosticato un piccolo tumore al seno
preso in uno stadio molto iniziale ma
che comunque la parola tumore fa sempre
paura per quanto questo piccolo per
quanto questo piccolo sia e ci siamo un
po'
il natale del 2014 eravamo in vacanza in
Italia quando il chirurgo ci disse
signora lei è un tumore al seno adesso
non deve pensare a curarsi e non
rientrare in Africa
Ci siamo messi un po' M'ha fatto un po'
sorridere questa questa cosa perché noi
pensiamo sempre che il tumore venga gli
altri ma mai a noi
è ancora lì abbiamo detto no no non
molliamo non lasciamolo Zambia e abbiamo
voluto coinvolgere i ragazzi in questa
decisione importante e abbiamo chiesto a
loro cosa volessero fare senza un attimo
di esitazione loro Ci dissero mamma tu
resti in Italia a curarti che noi ti
aspettiamo giù in Zambia e così è stato
io e Giuseppe me lo sono tenuti in
Italia con me ho iniziato tutto il
percorso Ho spostato la data del
biglietto l'ultima data di esposizione
resta giugno e sono andata dall'oncologo
gli ho detto Guardi dottore Io il 6
giugno sono in aereo e rientro a casa
così è stata sono stata super fortunata
aver incontrato medici e infermieri
meravigliosi una famiglia e mie sorelle
che mi hanno supportato non mi hanno mai
abbandonato
e anche questo è stato un pezzetto della
mia vita importante importante
perché ho avuto modo di trascorrere
tempo con la mia famiglia ricucire dei
rapporti che si erano allentati è
importante per i miei ragazzi Federico
perché anche loro hanno trovato di
fronte ad affrontare una situazione
difficile a non mollare mai a rialzarsi
sempre nei momenti delle difficoltà
e intanto gli anni sono passati e la
scuola il ciclo scolastico terminato e
siamo arrivati al momento dell'esame di
maturità perché l'esame di maturità
finora hanno fatto loro ma hanno fatto
anch'io perché coloro sofferto coloro
imparato coloro studiato e con loro
gioito dei loro successi e con la
conclusione del loro percorso scolastico
abbiamo visto anche la fine del progetto
per cui Enrico lavorava da tre anni e ci
siamo trovati ancora senza lavoro in
Africa e ancora di fronte al bivio a
decidere cosa fare restiamo o rientriamo
in Italia però a questo punto anche i
ragazzi hanno detto no perché loro hanno
sempre abbracciato la nostra scelta di
vita hanno detto No mamma si trova una
soluzione andiamo avanti e qui è
arrivato l'anno del Sudan yuba Sono
partita con un progetto sanitario
[Musica]
rincaricata di tre dispensari di una
farmacia questo mi ha permesso
economicamente di
aiutare i miei ragazzi a iniziare
l'università e aiutare me Enrico a far
uscire definitivamente il nostro sogno
dal cassetto di aprire una Ong
registrati in Italia e qui è nata
pamozzi Diana come modi Diana Si occupa
di educazione accesso all'Acqua e alla
salute ma il programma che più mi sta a
cuore è il programma di bambini disabili
affetti da paralisi cerebrale
retrocefalo e spina bifida vi aiutiamo
accedendo aiutandoli loro ad accedere
alle cure mediche e distribuiamo delle
carrozzine speciali questi per
migliorare la loro qualità di vita ma
non solo loro anche quello della
famiglia della famiglia estesa e per
rendere il loro mondo un modo migliore
la loro vita un po' migliore
Ecco ci ho impiegato un pochettino a
terminare di leggere il libro Don
Chisciotte ma è sempre piaciuto un sacco
la figura di Don Chisciotte perché non
nonostante le batoste nonostante le
derisioni non si è mai abbattuto non si
è mai scoraggiato sempre portato avanti
i suoi ideali e la sua voglia di
giustizia e Sancho Panza Fedele scudiero
che non ha mai abbandonato e lo ha
sempre seguito vedendolo un po' pazzo
che lottava contro i mulini a vento
pensandoli
dei mostri e l'ho sempre seguito e
difeso Ecco queste due figure devono
aiutare noi a far capire ad aiutarci a
difendere i nostri ideali Anche se sono
un po' fuori fuori moda e spero sempre
ehm la mia speranza è che la nostra
scelta di vita mia di Enrico il nostro
la nostra testimonianza abbia comunicato
questi messaggi i nostri figli
Grazie